this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by aura
on April 30th 1943 in the middle of
World War II a body washed up on the
shore of wellva Spain the deceased man
was wearing a British military uniform
there was a briefcase strapped to his
body containing British and American
Military Secrets the man was Major
William Martin a royal Marine who was
the single victim of a fatal plane crash
at Sea he just returned from temporary
leave in London where he had gone to the
theater and purchased an engagement ring
for his fiancee Pam but there was
something very strange about major
William Martin he didn't exist
I don't know he's about four inches long
and orange bright white teeth sometimes
he wears a tinfoil hat it's just
never mind detective I found him
where have you been
yeah
I don't understand what you're saying
can you stop moving for a second please
I know it's short for Gertrude
wait are you in a camel her name is
Gertie I'm sorry goonie I'm sorry baby
the human doesn't know what you saying
who's a good girl who's a good girl why
are you on a camel dirty why are you on
where are you
I keep getting these emails from an
Arabian a Mia so I came to find him a
mirror he means Prince I know what an
emir is
he told me that there's some trouble in
his Emirates
they help transfer money out of
the advantage you know that's a scam
right
that's who's gonna put your thing down
there is no a mirror
look you should just let Aura handle
this oh is that
no Aura is today's sponsor that makes
more sense data Brokers make a lot of
money selling your personal information
to scammers to robocallers
there is no never mind the point is Ora
can find out who's exposing your
information and submit opt-out requests
for you I already did that yeah I know
but these scammers use all kinds of
loopholes to make it almost impossible
to get your information off their lists
so just let Aura handle it
everybody hit me with the call to action
well you could try Aura for two weeks
completely free by going to aura.com the
Y files
Aura is the only app you'll need to
protect you from all kinds of dangers
online you get a VPN virus protection
password management identity theft
Insurance parental controls
yep
camel nip
never mind look at this chart
well you get on it okay I'm sold I'll
sign up as soon as I deal with this Amir
there is no aim here just go to aura.com
the Y files and get your two week trial
completely free there's a link below Hey
look
type of Desert Storm I know what it is
all right guys let's see in a couple of
days we should be back by hump day yeah
you get it yeah very funny
wait what do you mean we hey you're
gonna love Gertie oh you cannot bring
that it's really effective
don't you bring it don't worry
oh don't you dare bring it
it was the winter of 1942 and the Allies
needed a win Hitler's Nazi war machine
had steamrolled all of Europe and
everybody knew England was next the
United States had just been dragged into
the war by the attack on Pearl Harbor
and American bodies were piling up by
the thousands inside jab what Pearl
Harbor was an inside jab didn't you see
that image that was going around show me
you know that was meant as a joke maybe
and you know the Earth is round right
allegedly no it really is could be round
could be flat you know who's to say uh
science is to say oh right science I
tried to make air quotes but that my
fins wouldn't bend anyway German forces
were better trained better equipped and
of singular purpose but Germany did have
weakness it's not a country rich in
natural resources to wage war in the
1940s you need iron oil Rubber and food
Germany had to import all of these if
the Allies could disrupt Germany's
supply lines the Germans would no longer
have the ability to fight and the war
could come to a quick close but that was
easier said than done German Engineers
were among the best in the world every
time the German Army seized an inch of
land it was quickly fortified any Allied
Advance on Mainland Europe would be
repelled and would result in
catastrophic losses but the coastline of
the Mediterranean was not as heavily
fortified UK prime minister Winston
Churchill called this the soft
underbelly of Europe the key to taking
back Europe was Italy and the key to
taking Italy was Sicily unfortunately
the Germans understood the Strategic
importance of Sicily as well they were
fully expecting the Allies to attack it
if the Allies had any hope of winning
they'd need the element of surprise MI5
Britain's intelligence agency was tasked
with tricking the Germans into thinking
the Allies would attack Greece instead
if the Germans bought the ruse they
would divert forces from Sicily to
Greece leaving Sicily unprotected and
ensuring an easy win for the Allies one
of the British Intelligence Officers
working on Crafting this deception was
Charles Chumley hang on what shall we
danced it says in a screen yeah I know
that's how he pronounced his name well
he pronounced it wrong Chumlee's primary
role in the war effort was an ideas guy
Charles Chumley remembered a top secret
memo distributed to British wartime
intelligence at the beginning of the war
it became known as the trout memo
because it compared intelligence to fly
fishing why would anyone want to catch
flies no no fly fishermen try to catch
fish
those fishermen
the trout memo listed 51 specific ideas
for fooling the Germans the list was
pretty wacky and included dropping
glow-in-the-dark footballs in the water
to attract submarines there was one
about a fake treasure ship and there was
another about explosives being disguised
as food but the craziest idea in the
trout memo was number 28. it involved
loading up a corpse with phony documents
then dropping the corpse from a plane
Behind Enemy Lines and when you read the
entire trout memo you can't help but
think whoever thought of this stuff
would be great at writing spy novels
the trout memo officially was written by
rear Admiral John Godfrey but it was
actually written by Godfrey's assistant
Lieutenant Commander Ian Fleming the
same Ian Fleming who went on to become a
novelist best known for a series
featuring The Character band James Bond
idea number 28 on Ian Fleming's trout
memo was titled a suggestion and not a
very nice one
the following suggestion is used in a
book by basil Thompson a corpse dressed
as an Airman with dispatches in his
pockets could be dropped on the coast
supposedly from a parachute that had
failed I understand there is no
difficulty in obtaining corpses at the
naval hospital but of course it would
have to be a fresh one
the idea was so crazy that Chumley
thought it might be just the way to fool
the Germans into believing the Allies
were planning to attack Greece instead
of Sicily he presented it to his
superiors and they assigned a naval
officer named Ewan Montague to help him
develop the plan before the war Ewan
Montague was a lawyer he came from an
extremely wealthy family of bankers and
when the war broke out he was too old
for active service but found himself
Rising through the ranks of Naval
intelligence you know I noticed that
people from wealthy families tend to
rise to the ranks rather quickly yeah
that does seem to be the case as it
turned out an inclination for wartime
intelligence work ran in the family Ewan
didn't know it at the time but his own
brother Ivor Montague was actually a spy
for the Soviet Union uh-oh well luckily
the Soviet Union and the United Kingdom
were fighting this war on the same side
no that's true so did this uh Eagle
either
did he stop spying for the Russians
after the war
the montagues were also Jewish so ewan's
wife and children spent the war in
America for safety reasons Ewan wanted
in on this unique operation to serve his
country of course but also to keep his
mind off how much he missed his wife
Chumley Montague fleshed out the plan
for their mission they would deliver a
dead body via a submarine just off the
coast of Spain the body would be
carrying information identifying him as
a royal marine and most importantly
falsified documents regarding an
upcoming military offensive in Greece
Spain was the ideal country to find the
body because though they were officially
neutral they were in close communication
with the Germans and if military Secrets
washed up on the Spanish Shores there
was a good chance those Secrets would
end up in the hands of the Germans
chumlea Montague had the plan now they
just needed a dead body but not just any
dead body it had to be male and of
military age the cause of death needed
to line up with the story of a plane
crash at Sea so drowning exposure shock
or traumatic injury and the man
shouldn't have any pesky family members
who might not appreciate their loved
one's corpse being dressed up as someone
else and taken out of the country Ewan
Montague was friendly with a local
coroner who agreed to keep an eye out
for just such a body ah it's good to
have a co-op Sky it is and on January 26
1943 the coroner called Montague and
told him I got one
blender Michael had a hard life his
father attempted suicide by stabbing
himself in the neck with the knife he
was taken to a mental hospital where he
caught influenza and later died his
mother struggled to care for the family
on her own they were often homeless and
there was never enough food shortly
before the war she died of a heart
attack glender was declared ineligible
for military service though it's not
clear why it could have been for poor
physical health poor mental health or
both he eventually became homeless and
wandered the Streets of London on
January 26 1943 glendor Michael consumed
rat poison in an abandoned warehouse it
could have been suicide but most likely
he was starving and found some bread the
bread had been laced with rat poison and
glendor died two days later death by rat
poison is a rough way to go
but considering the forensic technology
available at the time dying for rat
poisoning could pass for drowning
Chumley amount of you now had a body not
for long no Montague's coroner buddy
Phillips guy is corpse guy stressed that
glendor's body was already starting to
decompose he could keep him on ice but
he needed to be deployed within the next
three months at this point Chumlee a
Montague's Mission had also been given
an official code name operation minspean
and this was a dark joke mincemeat is a
recipe combining chopped meat or animal
fat with fruit and spices and whatever
you've got lying around and when those
things you've got lying around include
sugar and alcohol it's a good way to
preserve meat at this time in the UK
people needed to preserve meat to make
their rations last longer but this time
the meat was a man
foreign
it turned out that acquiring a highly
specific dead body was the easy part
it's good to have a co-op Sky now
Montague and Chumley needed to create a
new identity from thin air and it had to
stand up to German scrutiny he needed to
be a military officer if it was going to
be believable that he had possession of
sensitive documents they chose the Royal
Marines because it was a common uniform
and easy to get to avoid the uniform
looking too new Chumley wore it every
day for the next three months now they
needed a name Montague and Chumley
looked through the list of servicemen
and found several Royal Marines named
William Martin who were around the rank
of Captain the Germans likely had access
to the same list of names but not their
postings so Montague and Chumley borrow
the name the fictional William Martin
also needed identification Royal Marines
carried ID cards on them at all times
that included a picture Montague and
Chumley attempted to photograph the dead
body but this was unsuccessful they
couldn't pull a Weekend at Bernie's
white tried but the body was in Rush
shape and getting worse the pictures
were frightening but working in another
department was a man who looked similar
to glender Michael and he was willing to
be photographed Montague and Chumley
barred his face there was one more thing
they needed but this one they wouldn't
be able to give back underwear a British
military officer at the time would have
been wearing underwear underwear was
rationed in the UK at the time meaning
you couldn't find it in a store and no
one was giving theirs up and this is the
way the expression going commando comes
from uh I don't think that's right well
well Montague presented this predicament
to one of his superiors and it just so
happened that one of his superiors
academic enemies had recently been run
over by a truck he was delighted to
acquire his former colleagues underwear
for operation mincemeat Montague and
Chumley now turned their attention from
the physical to the fictional they
needed a backstory for major William
Martin every night they would go out
with a few of their colleagues and fill
in details on William Martin's backstory
he liked fishing and was bad with money
he was romantic and secretly wanted to
be a writer the team came to view major
William Martin as a friend the backstory
they created would be told to the
Spanish who found the body and hopefully
the Germans they showed it to in the
form of pocket litter pocket litter is
the term for the random stuff people
carry in their pockets for the fictional
William Martin that included his
falsified military ID Card the military
documents hinting at the Allied plans to
invade Greece to get stubs from the
theater a receipt for an engagement ring
an overdraft letter from the bank and a
photograph and love letter from his
fiancee Pam Gene Leslie a secretary
working at the agency agreed to provide
a photograph Gene now became major
Martin's fiance Pam and here's where
things get a little awkward Ewan and
Jean began spending a lot of time
together they went dancing they went to
the movies but not as themselves not as
you and Eugene as William and Pam they
may have been playing characters but the
romance was real enough that Montague's
own mother wrote to his wife suggesting
she come back to the UK as soon as she
could but there was one last very
important letter to be written the
military communication from a general
revealing the supposed joint American
and British attack on Greece the work on
this letter took over a month and after
many drafts were written by an
increasingly frustrated you and Montague
they just had the general write the
letter himself nobody likes getting
notes that's true
and in the letter was placed a single
eyelash
yep the British needed to know if the
letter was opened if the plan worked
they'd have the documents returned to
them if the eyelash was missing that
means someone opened the letter
but the month of rewrites was a problem
considering the three-month window given
to operation mincemeat by the coroner
Sky they needed to get glinder Michael
the photo of Gene the worn uniform The
Love Letters the dead academics
underwear the all-important military
document and the pocket litter to Spain
and they needed to do it fast because
acting major William Martin was starting
to rot
at this time MI5 employed one of the
UK's most famous race car drivers during
the war Jack Horsfall had been recruited
by British intelligence to provide
transportation for its agents when they
needed to get somewhere and get out of
somewhere fast in this case he needed to
transport you and Montague Charles
Chumley and a secret package from
England to Scotland where Ewan and
Charles would meet a submarine that
would deliver major William Martin to a
specific location off the coast of Spain
glinder Michael's body had been placed
in a special container that was created
for this exact purpose it was
essentially a thin coffin packed with
dry ice this would help keep the body
cold to slow down the decomposition
process and help keep it secret it would
also save the submarine's crew from
being trapped in a small space with a
very bad smell they decided to travel
overnight to risk being seen But the UK
was under a strict blackout at the time
every night entire cities went dark to
make them harder for German bombers to
identify from overhead this meant all
street lights were out and all vehicle
headlights had to be covered so Montague
and Chumley were going to be driven at
high speed by a race car driver in Pitch
darkness and by the way Jack Horsfall
was legally blind and refused to wear
glasses
well maybe or stupid horse fall wouldn't
wear glasses because he was always very
well dressed he liked martinis and was
famous for driving in Aston Martin which
is like James Bond
you'll be using this Aston Martin DB5
with modifications
now pay attention please
[Music]
James Bond was a composite character
based on real people that Ian Fleming
knew including Jack Horsfall the
overnight road trip from England to
Scotland was crazy and included a couple
of close calls but they made it to
Scotland on time in Scotland they met
the crew of the submarine HMS serif and
loaded in their suspiciously large
container which was labeled Optical
instruments in the early morning hours
of April 30th 1943 the submarine reached
its destination the officers aboard the
HMS serif performed a brief funeral
service for glendor Michael then placed
his body with the briefcase attached
into the water then the sub was
positioned in a way that the propellers
could be used to propel the body toward
the shore begun the engine and the body
was on its way their final task was to
sink the body's container and this
turned out to be one of the biggest
hurdles operation mincemeat faced part
of the special containers cooling system
included air pockets and so when placed
in the water it floated they tried
shooting at it but it still wouldn't
think and if they couldn't sink it this
would be a big problem imagine a strange
coffin riddled with bullet holes washing
up on shore just after major William
Martin's body the Spanish would know
things were not as they seemed so the
serif crew decided to blow it up the
explosion was loud but the container did
finally sink and major Martin he ended
up on the beach
foreign
9 30 on the morning of April 30th 1943
the body of Royal Marine acting major
William Martin was discovered by a
fisherman in wellva Spain this was
chosen as the drop-off site because of
one specific well of a resident Adolf
Klaus that's the most German name I ever
heard Klaus was a notorious German spy
who was the key to making sure the
falsified documents were seen by the
Germans the fishermen who found the body
notified the Spanish authorities who
informed the British Consulate in Spain
and now began a delicate diplomatic
dance after enough time had passed for
news of major William Martin's death to
travel through official British channels
the British needed to start requesting
Martin's briefcase and by pushing for
the return of the briefcase it would
alert the Spanish and hopefully the
Germans that there was something juicy
inside but they couldn't push too hard
where the Spanish might return the
briefcase before the Germans could get a
peak but they did eventually need to get
the documents back if this thing was
going to work
because look if the Germans believed
that the British believed that their
documents had been lost and the Germans
had possibly gained possession of them
they would likely cancel the planned
Greek attack no reason to attack if the
Germans know it's coming and that
couldn't be allowed to happen the
Germans had to read the letter and have
it returned unopened so a delicate dance
less delicate was the matter of the
autopsy glinder Michael had of course
not died by drowning or blunt trauma or
shock or exposure he ate rat poison a
detailed autopsy would almost certainly
have revealed that something was off but
by this time the stench of the body was
so foul that the British Vice Consul who
was aware of operation mincemeat was
able to cut the autopsy short he told
the staff in the coroner's office
it's hot this place stinks let's go grab
lunch instead I'm buying and that was
the end of the autopsy a few days later
a funeral was held for major William
Martin he was buried in Spain with full
military honors among the crowd of
mourners was the German spy Adolf Klaus
Adolf knew about major William Martin's
arrival in Spain and was already working
on obtaining a copy of the documents now
it took a week and a half but the
documents did make their way into the
hands of the Germans before finally
being returned no eyelash no eyelash
to get the letter out of the envelope
the Germans inserted a thin wire and
actually wound the letter into a tight
scroll the scroll was carefully pulled
from a small fold in the envelope it was
dried copied twisted around the wire
again and put back in the envelope
without breaking the wax seal it was
then soaked in seawater and returned
even if the eyelash was there the
British would have known the letter was
red because when they dried it out it
curled up like a potato chip and then
the information from the falsified
documents made it all the way to Hitler
foreign
1943 The Joint American and British
Invasion of Sicily codenamed operation
husky began the Allies were met with
Stormy Weather but little German
resistance the enemy was too busy
planning for the invasion of Greece
Hitler had bought the operation
mincemeat deception completely the
British had expected ten thousand killed
or wounded in the first week of fighting
but only suffered 1400 losses the Navy
expected the 300 ships would be sunk in
the action but they lost only 12. the
predicted 90-day campaign was over in 38
days operation mincemeat is now
considered one of the greatest episodes
of wartime deception in history and is
broadly credited with one of the turning
points of World War II but this
successful operation had a dark side
effect it ushered in a new era of
Espionage it opened a Pandora's box of
intelligence operations focused on
Deception but the targets of the
deception were no longer military the
targets were now civilians in 1942 the
United States military created oss the
office of strategic services this was an
intelligence agency modeled after
Britain's MI6 after the war the OSS was
dissolved but in 1947 a new intelligence
agency was created the CIA
technically the CIA is a civilian agency
tasked with Gathering processing and
analyzing National Security information
from around the world but Cia operations
are much more creative and devious than
simple intelligence gathering in 1953
the CIA helped overthrow Iran's
government via Operation Ajax in 1954
operation PB success overthrew the
president of Guatemala a democratically
elected president Syria Indonesia Brazil
Nicaragua Haiti Uruguay Panama and these
countries and many others the CIA
attempted coups attempted to remove
elected leaders and in some cases
assassinate those leaders
the 1962 Cuban Missile Crisis is taught
in every American school it's a story
about Soviet aggression and The Bravery
of President JFK what's not taught is
that in the Years leading up to the
crisis the CIA established a base of
operations in Miami the only place that
had more CIA officers in the world was
headquarters in Langley these men
belonged to a terrorist organization
responsible for a recent wave of
bombings kidnappings and assassinations
they are Cuban Exiles waging a terrorist
war against Fidel Castro and their base
of operations is an American city from
the Miami base operation JM wave was
launched Cuban Exiles were recruited and
trained by the CIA to operate as agents
those agents then spent years engaging
in an extensive campaign of terrorism on
economic and civilian targets a lot of
civilians were killed and this was a
major factor in the Soviet decision to
place missiles on Cuba these terrorist
attacks continued for years in 1976
Cubana flight 455 was destroyed by a
bomb killing all 73 people aboard the
CIA was immediately suspected but
naturally they denied it but in 2007
independent research connected the
bombing to a CIA asset
during the Vietnam war the CIA spun up
The Phoenix Program this program was
designed to identify and destroy the
Viet Cong the VC by infiltration
assassination terrorism and torture
Phoenix was shut down after the abused
torture and murder were exposed in the
1970s back home the cia's operation
chaos targeted anti-war protesters I
thought the CIA was
overseas and doesn't spy in Americans
yeah yeah I realized how stupid I
sounded when I said it hey it's a good
thing that the CAA FBI and other
agencies aren't being weaponized and
used against American citizens uh
sarcasm
Operation Condor ran for over 20 years
and was a program of terrorism
assassination and overthrow attempts of
every socialist leader in South America
there's compelling evidence to show that
for over 30 years the CIA helped
organize train and fund death squads in
El Salvador during the U.S inspired
Civil War at least 75 000 civilians were
killed MK Ultra was an illegal human
experimentation program the CIA was
testing drugs that could be used to
force confessions through brainwashing
and psychological torture the program
ran for 20 years before being exposed
through the 80s and 90s the CIA was the
biggest illegal drug trafficking and
money laundering operation in the world
though this is only alleged operation
mincemeat is hailed as a great success a
major turning point in World War II that
led to the Allied Victory and probably
saved millions of lives and I believe
that's true but out of the ashes of the
war and emboldened by the success of the
OS s emerged the CIA
now the CIA and its Defenders will say
that yes mistakes were made but the
ultimate goal of the agency is to
protect American lives and America's
interests overseas and that's what we're
taught here in the U.S and that's what
we're shown in every movie about the CIA
which all have to be approved by the CIA
but there are people around the world
and throughout history that view the CIA
as an instrument of evil thousands
perhaps millions of people would say the
CIA is the most villainous organization
ever conceived by man and I'm not saying
it is I'm just saying every story has
two sides so is the CIA a hero or a
villain well it all depends on which
side of the table you're sitting on
which end of the gun you are on which
end of the needle on whether you're the
tortured or the torturer
now given the nightmarish abuses and
atrocities it's committed and given the
political weaponization of the agency
that exists today the CIA at least the
way it's currently structured might be
doing more harm than good but if America
is going to have a powerful intelligence
agency like the CIA and I think it
should that agency needs to do better
and we the people we need to demand it
thanks again to our sponsor Aura use the
link in the description to get two free
weeks and protect your online life right
Gertie
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ there's Heckle fish
what's cracking this has been the
y-files if you had fun or learned
anything do him a favor like subscribe
comment share
I know I'm a broken record it's annoying
they all say to do it but it actually
really does help and like most topics we
cover here on the channel today's is
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips and big thanks to
our patrons you guys are amazing and
without your generosity there would be
no white files I'm grateful you're out
there now if you'd like to join a great
Community join the Y files Discord it's
free and it's fun but if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon or grab something from
the Wi-Fi store grab yourself a heck of
fish t-shirt they're 100 guaranteed to
have not been worn by any corpses in an
intelligence operation
I hope me too pal that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]